SINGLE ADULT OR TEENAGE MALES.
>> Sean: TRACE GALLAGHER IN
LOS ANGELES TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
ALSO AS PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIES TO
SECURE OUR SOUTHERN BORDER,
DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO DEMONIZE
AGENTS AND SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS
SAID THIS JUST LAST WEEK AT THE
CONFIRMATION HEARING FOR TRUMP'S
PICK TO LEAD I.C.E.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS OUTRAGE.
>> THE PLAN WAS WHAT WE WOULD
CALL TODAY A DOMESTIC TERRORIST
GROUP.
>> WHY WOULD WE CALL THEM A
DOMESTIC TERRORIST GROUP?
>> WE TRY TO USE FEAR AND FORCE
TO CHANGE THE POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT.
IT WAS BASED ON RACE AND
ETHNICITY.
>> RIGHT.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THE PERCEPTION
OF MANY, HOW THE POWER AND THIS
DISCRETION AT I.C.E. IS BEING
USED TO ENFORCE THE LAW?
AND DO YOU SEE ANY PARALLELS?
>> I DON'T SEE A PARALLEL.
>> THE PERCEPTION OF I.C.E.
BEING THE KKK?
HERE WITH REACTION, FORMER
ACTING FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU REACT TO
KAMALA HARRIS, AND, THERE ARE NO
GOOD ANSWERS HERE IN THE PEOPLE
IN MEXICO ARE USING
DONALD TRUMP'S VERBIAGE AND
LANGUAGE, THE FEELING THAT THIS
IS AN INVASION, BECAUSE THEIR
BORDERS WERE NOT RESPECTED.
THEIR LAWS WERE NOT RESPECTED.
>> FIRST OF ALL, WHAT SHE DID
WAS DISGUSTING.
SHE COMPARED THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF ICE AND THOSE WOMEN AND MEN
LEAVE THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
THEIR HOME EVERY DAY AND FOR
THOSE AS A U.S. SENATOR  , ICE I
THOSE AS A U.S. SENATOR  , ICE S
ENFORCING THE LAWS THAT CONGRESS
ENACTED.
THEY ARE NOT MAKING THIS UP.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THIS CARAVAN
TODAY.
SHE SHOULD GO WALK TO THE
NATIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
MEMORIAL AND APOLOGIZE ALL OF
THE AGENTS THAT GAVE THEIR LIVES
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT TAKES
BORDER SECURITY SERIOUSLY.
HE'S DOING HIS JOB.
AND THESE PEOPLE WENT THROUGH
THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND
ASSAULTED THEIR FEDERAL OFFICERS
THAT WERE USED IN THE MILITARY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TAKING POWER,
AND, OUR BORDER IS CLOSED FOR
ILLEGAL BUSINESS.
SO FOR THE CARAVAN TO BE STUCK
IN TIJUANA, HE PUT THE ISSUE ON
THE FRONT BURNER.
I'M CERTAINLY GLAD HE IS THERE.
AND HE WILL BE SUCCESSFUL.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE PROTESTERS
IN TIJUANA, AND, MEXICO IS NOT
PREPARED TO DEAL WITH ANY OF
THIS, AND NOW, IT HAS GOTTEN TO
THE POINT WHERE WE GOT THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE AND NO PLACE TO GO
WHICH IS BEING LAUGHED AT BY
PEOPLE, AND THIS IS JUST
FEARMONGERING AND APPARENTLY IT
DOESN'T --
>> APPARENTLY, THEY MOVED TO TRY
TO ACCESS THE UNITED STATES
THROUGH TIJUANA BECAUSE THE DRUG
CARTELS ARE UNHAPPY.
THE IMPEDIMENTS AREN'T AT THE
BORDER, AND THAT AFFECTS THEIR
ABILITY TO MOVE DRUGS INTO THE
COUNTRY.
64,000 DEATHS FROM HEROIN AND
OTHER OPIOID OVERDOSES, BUT
PRIMARILY HEROIN IN THIS COUNTRY
IN 2016.
64,000 DEAD AMERICANS AND
REGARDING KAMALA HARRIS SPEAKING
ABOUT THE DRUG TRAFFICKING INTO
THE INTERIOR, I.C.E. IS THE
ORGANIZATION THAT SAVES LIVES
AND IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES, LEGAL
AND ILLEGAL, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WHEN THEY DEAL WITH MS-13, THE
SEX TRAFFICKING AND THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING, THE KIDNAPPING OF
CHILDREN TO FORCE THEM INTO THE
GANGS AND FORCE THEM INTO THE
ABUSE.
IT'S ICE THAT GET THE CRIMINALS.
THEY RISK LIVES TO SAVE THE
LIVES OF THE COMMUNITIES, AND
PEOPLE IN THE URBAN AREAS IS THE
SCENE AND IT HIGHLIGHTS A FRAUD
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOW, AND
ESPECIALLY THE WOMEN WHO ARE
CLAIMING TO BE FEMINISTS LEADING
THAT PARTY.
YOU ARE CONDEMNING GIRLS AND
WOMEN IN THE PROCESS OF THIS